so what kind of stars have been
discovered so you've uh already a while
ago uh helped discover the star he
1327 2326 great name yes and uh Chief
15230901 what can you say about these
these stars and others that have been
found I love them okay they're my baby
Stars what do you call what do you call
what do you call your your baby Stars
well I'm probably the only one who can
you know spit out these names without
cheating there's nicknames are there
nickels no that's that's that's that's
not allowed okay uh well some colleagues
at conferences have just call them Anna
style fribosa because they they didn't
want to learn the the phone number you
know I I get it phone number yeah and
these numbers are actually based on on
older sets of coordinates for these
Stars so they um yes the the minus in
the middle means that they're in the
southern hemisphere so negative is in
the Southern Hemisphere and positive is
and then we're then and then uh 13 and
15 means that sort of observable in the
middle of of the Year okay so that's to
do with the observation and where it was
observed yes yes but um they have very
different stores
um both absolutely significant
um career defining actually for for me
but um really push pushed the envelope
in in very different ways so 80 1327 of
the first one that you mentioned that
was the second second generation star
that we found and you know usually
people say like oh the first one is the
big one and the rest is nobody cares but
to us it proved that yes we can do it
because one astronomers live in this
sort of way of you know there are a lot
of serendipitous discoveries and we
that's really great but we need to show
that we can do it again reliably because
then then we're on to something it's not
just some kind of weird Quirk and there
are a lot of quirks in the universe but
we want to know is is that a real thing
does that happen regularly is there
something that we can learn right is
that a piece of the story
and so finding the second one that was
even a little bit more extreme than the
first one really showed yes our search
techniques work we can find these Stars
they provide an important part to the
story
in the sense that
if we had more than two stars and by now
we have about 10ish or so
what do they tell us about the nature of
the very first Stars